we need to talk about YouTube shorts one
of the biggest opportunities right now
on YouTube for getting views extra money
YouTube shorts are making major waves
this is like one of those podcasts that
I think is so important YouTube shorts
are getting 30 billion views per day
YouTube shorts could be its own platform
people are getting brand deals on short
videos you gotta pay attention to them
this is definitely a must listen to take
notes during this one
I'm gonna be hanging out with Nolan molt
from the team think media and we're
going to be discussing the opportunity
for you and how you can leverage it this
year Nolan how's it going so good I am
so stoked about YouTube shorts I've been
experimenting with them just on many
different YouTube channels small YouTube
channels are two point you know 2
million think media YouTube channel our
podcast Channel we've been posting daily
shorts uh which is under 100K
subscribers and so I'm excited too and I
know we just there's
stories we've been helping people and
people are using it I'm excited to talk
all things and really help this is like
one of those podcasts that I think is so
important YouTube shorts have kind of
been around a little bit but like it is
so fresh so so fresh and so clean so
fresh and so new and so this is
definitely a must Listen to I think
people need to take notes during this
one yeah what's Wild is actually YouTube
shorts are two years old now
pretty crazy because it doesn't feel
like it's enough it doesn't it feels
like they're so brand new and they
really are in terms of the opportunity
in the second part of the podcast we'll
talk about strategy but in the first
part let's just talk about some of the
stats and so here's some things people
need to know
um already as of listening to this
shorts are open for a higher level of
monetization there was the shorts fund
but now YouTube is splitting Revenue
with creators uh you're gonna do a video
on think media that's kind of revealing
how that works and how there's a pool
and the music companies get their cut
first and then eventually creators get
45 YouTube gets 55 but all of that aside
the point is you can earn revenue from
YouTube shorts specifically
at a higher level so that's an
opportunity and also when YouTube
premium subscribers watch your content
in YouTube shorts they'll be paying you
at a higher level also YouTube shorts
are getting 30 billion views per day
and that's an older stat and that was 4X
increase from the year before but that's
almost a year old stat so I'm sure those
numbers are higher and YouTube shorts
has 1.5 billion logged in users watching
them every month and they're touted by
YouTube as a feeder for long form
content so it's important to know that
even if you don't love shorts using them
can be a gateway to your longer form
content but I'm sure those numbers have
gone up but if you were to isolate that
because if YouTube has 2.6 billion
monthly logged in users and there's 1.5
billion of those that are consuming
shorts then it's almost like YouTube
shorts could be its own platform bigger
than Twitter bigger than Instagram maybe
I don't know what Instagrams monthly
active users are but you know massive
but but then YouTube overall is even
bigger than that and then this one was
wild and I'm curious your take on this
so you can go to tubefilter.com at any
time and look at the top 50 YouTube
channels in any given week and the last
one I was able to pull even though it's
way past this the last one that came up
for me was the beginning of 2023 it was
like the first week in in January of
2023 the 50 most viewed U.S YouTube
channels and I counted 40 out of the 50
were shorts channels meaning well I
don't know what it means but there's a
little I think what it means is they're
either heavy shorts or all shorts
because there's a little logo on the
tube filter page that shows that they
are shorts and some of the titles of the
channels
were like such and such comedy shorts
yeah or whatever so man so that's out of
the top 50 that's a sign I mean there's
signals and signs we need to be paying
attention to and then thinking about how
we can apply those into our own world
what what are some of those stats make
you feel well just on that last one it
makes sense because uh Ryan Trahan he
just posted a YouTube video and um he
gets a lot of views right he's he's one
of those viral YouTube guys and uh but
he posts a short and it's just low-key
because it's it's not even in the
subscription feed but like if you go to
his channel you look at his shorts
within like the first day he's getting
like 25 million views on a short and I'm
not surprised and it really is like as a
viewer it's more of a commitment anyways
to watch an eight ten minute long vid
YouTube video versus watching a 15 to 60
second YouTube short
um and so you can just watch so many
more of them yeah I I think I think that
number actually will just increase the
40 out of top 50. I I think that number
just gets higher and higher as even with
monetization people are going to be
posting more shorts because they want to
make money and I'm excited to see what
that looks like as as we start to you
know get those checks and collect the
check but all this stuff is it's
exciting for me and a lot of people that
I know
um will I'm sure we'll get into this
Sean they get into the negatives of like
it's ruining my average view duration
they don't watch my long form videos I
got a hundred thousand subscribers and
I'm only getting a thousand views on my
videos and you know people tend to focus
on the negatives but I like that like
you're sharing facts and I want to look
at that and help people
um make the most out of it and so yeah
I'm excited to to get into that yeah so
we'll talk about strategy in a second
but the the last section of kind of the
new data is some tools and so the
there's going to be a new card on the
mobile version of YouTube Studio that
will show creators which videos their
viewers are watching so that means that
YouTube studio and analytics is going to
split out shorts data for you which is
kind of cool yeah we already have that
even for our Channel like if we look at
you can now go to uh click the shorts
Tab and if you go over and let's say we
want to look at 2022 we had
um four million views in shorts and I
believe just this year with some of the
new strategies that we're going to be
doing uh you know I think we're gonna
exponentially increase that number uh
but 11.2
000 subscribers as well
um just from shorts so pretty cool and
uh yeah you can pull that now in terms
of you're pulling up desktop but this is
the YouTube app is going to add a card
nice which will be like a particular I'm
actually updating my YouTube studio app
right now to see
and there's always that's actually one
thing if you're listening to this number
one a lot of people don't even have the
YouTube studio app it's different than
the YouTube app number two make sure
it's updated because they can give you
different insights in terms of analytics
and things inside of there and so um
that was one thing another was
thumbnails this is kind of interesting
yes and so the new development on
YouTube shorts concerns one of the most
studied Topics in online video Community
which is thumbnails on Android shorts
users can select a specific frame from
the video to serve as the clips preview
image it's a pretty big deal because you
do see the preview images on the short
Shelf
and it also is a big deal because let's
say a lot of shorts in some niches are
are like interviews back and forth like
you and I yeah so the thumbnails should
probably be one of us you can't really
get two people into it and if it's a
conversation back and forth and it edits
back and forth then it's probably going
to be one of us the question would be
who should it be if it's like uh if you
have a guest on you'd probably want it
to be the guest the bad thing is if you
can't select the thumbnail you either
have to think about the first frame all
that to say is that on Android you could
do this but YouTube is going to be
making thumbnails
more optimizable and clickable I don't
know if they'll allow us to upload
custom thumbnails I don't know if that'd
even be best practice if that'd be
effective but I do know and I believe on
iPhone you could do that as well but not
on desktop you can only do the
selectable
uh frame I think it's coming on Android
first and then it will roll out onto
iPhone is what is what it looks like but
that is huge though because when you go
to the app and you open up YouTube you
typically only see like three shorts
when most people are viewing shorts on
their phone so when you open up the
YouTube app and you just go to like your
subscription feed or your home page on
like actually it's only two I'm seeing
two videos and so am I going to choose
this one or this one and the first thing
I look at is that thumbnail the second
thing I look at is the title and so I
really think this is going to you know I
know there's going to be some creators
who are going to flash one frame that is
gonna be like a custom thumbnail it's
gonna flash one frame at the end uh
people on Instagram you know would do
this a lot and
um I that might work we'll have to wait
and see once that rolls out and um that
could be a way to kind of hack the
YouTube algorithm and you can kind of
customize it that way but overall I
think this is a a good step and
something you should definitely be doing
uh because I do think the that click
through it when it's one out of two and
people are clicking this one over that
one I think that will matter with the
algorithm so
um something people if you have Android
definitely start using that as soon as
possible and one other thing was
location tags so when uploading short
form video you can now employ location
tags
YouTube live from your mobile app
allowed you to use location I don't know
how how helpful that is but it very well
could be for news or vlogging type of
content because
um when if you were someplace where
somebody else wants to tour Downtown
Disney or something you log in there or
Yellowstone National Park or something
the fact you could do a location tag
becomes what it says here is the goal is
to add another layer of customization
um and so just these are all just
different distinctions so YouTube's
investing heavily in shorts of course
it's a major competitor because vertical
video is taking over everywhere A lot of
people don't know that Pinterest is
doing vertical video and of course Tick
Tock and reels and Facebook reels and so
shorts is only going to continue to grow
the data is supporting that 40 of the
top 50 channels even though I don't
think that would tell our community that
you should drop everything and go all in
in shorts It's you got to pay attention
to them it would be irresponsible to
ignore shorts which brings us to some
strategy
um tips let's land the plane on talking
about what what are people's next steps
and what are some advice for uh doing
shorts my first tip
is even if like you mentioned this
inspired me you said I got you know 100
000 views or 100 000 subscribers but I'm
only getting like a thousand views on a
short the thing is you just don't have
that much to lose
because rather than saying I only got
what about gaining viewers that you may
not have gained otherwise
right and I think the thing about shorts
when you also said they're easier for
people to consume with I would actually
argue that there is so many people
you'll never reach if you don't use
shorts because they'll never
try you out before fully committing I
think the world is so busy right now
there's so much noise that people want
the sample before they get the full
thing and we've been talking about the
Cinnabon strategy here at think media
you know and anybody who remembers
shopping malls remembers that there'd be
somebody in the food court standing out
with a tray of samples of Cinnabon that
were absolutely irresistible and I'm
walking by myself and I would walk up to
the lady and be like hey can I grab one
for me and then three for my friends and
then she's like sure you know and it's
like I ate all four probably not the
most ethical thing but hey this is me at
15 years old walking in the shopping
mall and so
you know you try it first and then
you're like man that's so good and then
the goals that you go buy the full
length you know the full size Cinnabon
sit down have an incredible sugar high
and then absolutely crash and ruin the
rest of your day and so shorts are like
people to hit a long form video or a
long form video podcast
like getting someone to go from zero to
a hundred with you like that is kind of
crazy getting somebody if you you're not
sure you want to eat the full-size
Cinnabon like that's a lot to to chew if
you do the sample first and that's
really the shorts uh or the their
snackable content it's a gateway to long
form and I kind of have a successful
um kind of uh story about this I started
a brand new channel it's a basketball
Channel and I was just experimenting
with different features and there's this
feature on mobile specifically called
remix and if you click that button if
it's your own video you can click down
to uh create a short and from there you
can do 15 or you can extend to 60
seconds and I was like let me just play
with this and see what happens and so my
first video long form video maybe got
six views in the first day and half of
them were me and so I was like let me
just try this remix short feature and
see what happens within the first like
15 minutes I got a couple thousand views
and I was like this is really weird and
it just it's it's PR and this was uh
about a month ago and this still is
happening right now and so it just
proved to me you know and I picked the I
picked a good clip for it to happen but
they're pushing shorts and what I found
was someone commented on that short and
and I and I can't remember now the name
of that person but I remember who it was
at the time because I had no comments
like no subs it was just me subscribed
to the channel and so a week later I
posted another long form video that
commenter ended up commenting on one of
my long form videos and I'm like
this dude found me on shorts yes and
then now he watched one of my long form
videos and so here's what's really
powerful about YouTube shorts right now
and they work with your long-form videos
so what you'll notice just as a viewer
if you watch a brand new long form video
just through the browse page you
actually next time you open up YouTube I
guarantee you you're gonna see their
videos in the short shelf because
they're like you like their long form
stuff you probably like they're short
and I and that obviously is working the
other way around as well you I don't use
short the shorts feet as much I usually
watch long form so for the people who
are watching shorts a lot they're now
like I really you know I started binging
think Media stuff they're going to get
recommended our long-form video so I one
of my major takeaways at vid Summit was
that people should be posting both long
form and shorts and they actually help
grow each other and so it's really
really powerful when you combine them
and and that's I think the key and you
know I want to get into some strategies
too on like what kind of content should
you because I think some people they
miss the mark and their shorts are just
so different than what their long-form
stuff is and so a perfect example is
like this podcast right now someone
might be watching this as a short they
can click on our Channel they can watch
the full podcast that's pretty awesome
but some people might just take out
their iPhone and shoot a random short
has nothing to do with their long-form
content and so I think do you have any
advice there when it comes to what kind
of content
um should people be posting like what
should they be thinking about when
they're going shorts and long form yeah
I think the question is why did people
subscribe in the first place what value
did they subscribe for and what are they
expecting like shorts are just a
different content format for hopefully
the same thing you're still delivering
the same promise yes it's a limited it's
60 seconds or less and it's vertical and
so maybe it's a quick tip instead of 52
tips in a long form video or it's not a
long form interview but it's one nugget
and so keeping it aligned to respect the
viewer would be my first tip but what
are some of your strategies when it
comes to shorts well I think you know
there's definitely there's a few
strategies that you can do but I totally
agree it's like it needs to align with
your overall theme for the channel
because you don't want your shorts to be
different that someone subscribes so
that when they those people see your
long form video they don't click that
hurts your click-through rate and now
you're hurting your channel some people
are are doing that now I do think though
there's certain audiences and niches
that just prefer the short form content
and that's okay people get discouraged
though because they're like I get
millions of views on my short form
content and I'm not getting views on my
long form content I'm like well that's
sick you're getting millions of views
yeah you can still monetize it and so
people get discouraged because they want
the long-form views for the AdSense but
we'll see what AdSense kind of looks
like on shorts but what I'm excited
about and I've just seen with some of my
Tick Tock Creator friends people people
are getting brand deals on short videos
like that's pretty awesome there I just
think over these next couple years as
shorts continue to grow there's going to
be so many more ways to actually make
money you can do brand deals there's
going to be ways for you to uh do
affiliate marketing and to grow your
audience and to make money and so I
would I would tell people you know if
Shorts are really popular like just lean
into that um obviously people got to pay
bills and stuff but uh you know there's
other ways that you can do that but yeah
yeah I want to hear the rest your
strategies one thing too that I just
remembered was we just released a brand
new deep dive shorts master class and so
I think at
shortsclass.com people can get access to
that it's a super great price if you
want tactical step-by-step education of
leveraging shorts and so uh we'll put a
link to the show notes
um but one of the things and we pulled
some of the best practice practices from
creators of all different backgrounds
there was one Creator who grew a million
subscribers in one month just posting
shorts and one of the things he
discovered was stories do well and
here's an opening people can use and you
may have noticed this before if you open
with you won't believe and more more
narrowed down if you open with you the
first word is you because like you need
to see
you've got to see this really cool
coffee maker that's perfect for people
doing van life or RV trips
you won't believe this now one of the
things that is also happening is stories
some entrepreneurs are telling stories
of businesses not even their own
business but stories really do well on
shorts and uh another one is this guy
this guy created clothes that grow with
you I think I just saw a creator making
that and and you're telling a story and
you're just pulling them right into it
the mistake people make on shorts is the
hook it's almost like there shouldn't
even be it the Hook's like one second
the hook is like the first word the hook
is like the first frame as opposed to
you definitely aren't introducing
yourself team things up it's all it's
it's a condensed perfect video formula
my major tip and I had a brand new
channel right go uh within the first 60
Minutes of releasing my first kind of
fully edited short I just try to do it
the best I could I got 70 000 views it
now has over 2 million views and so
there's a few takeaways that I had from
that that I I have a full video kind of
breaking that down on think media that
we'll put a link in the description but
here's what I tell people think about
the shorts feed you're scrolling up and
down you don't get to choose what video
you get to watch you either just watch
it or you go on to the next one there's
not a title or a thumbnail that you're
selecting when it's in the short speed
and so what I'm telling people is the
first few seconds of your short is your
thumbnail and your title how can you
hook that person in not to click on your
video because it's different how how can
you hook them in to keep watching and
those tips you shared are perfect ways
to start off your video and so you want
to jump right into the content instantly
and keep going and keep their attention
uh with my short that went viral one of
the methods that I used is the loop
method which at the very end of the
video it seamlessly goes to the
beginning of the video and uh that kind
of helped just boost the retention a
little bit more because it was so
seamless you don't want the video to
sound like it's ending at all you want
it to either end abruptly without anyone
knowing or you want it to just flow
right into the beginning and another
thing that a friend told me who he
claimed he cracked the code when it came
to YouTube shorts so he was telling me
he's like dude all you got to do is is
that as it's easy right all you got to
do is post 42 to 46 second long uh or no
sorry you guys you just need a 42 to 46
second long average view duration so I
was like okay and then he goes and you
want or he said he said 42 to 46 seconds
long video with a 90 retention rate and
that's exactly what I did I was able to
hit that retention rate uh and I think
my videos like or just under 50 seconds
long and so I think there is something
about 50 you know 45 to 60 second long
as long as you can keep the attention
there
um but then again I've seen articles of
15 second 30 second uh shorts blowing up
so experiment but really focus in on
those first few seconds hooking them in
and then make sure that the rest of the
content if you are going to make it
longer that it's Snappy it's quick it's
on to the next thing yeah well there's
so much we could get into and uh
literally as we're recording this
podcast we are in the final minutes of
our battery life and at the end of our
shoot day and all that stuff too and I'm
sure that our community has a lot of
questions about shorts as well and so I
do want to highly recommend uh one take
short seriously to do your research and
do your study and then three if you
actually want just some step-by-step
information to take the shortcut into
mastering shorts we did do a 90-minute
master class on
um YouTube shorts it's at
shortsclass.com and you can check that
out and this is one of the things we're
really geeking out on here at think
media and so we're putting in really
combined hundreds and thousands of hours
of research and testing consolidating
those best practices and we're including
some cool bonuses with this um shorts
master class as well so if you're
serious about shorts and uh want to
check that out you can check it out in
the show notes
shortsclass.com it will definitely be
worth your time and Nolan I'm excited to
uh see what this year brings when it
comes to YouTube shorts I'm excited I'm
sure we're going to have a few follow-up
episodes in the future so stay tuned for
that hit the Subscribe button and uh
we'll see you guys in the next episode